en efecto los resultados que se conocen
de manera extraoficial a partir de un
exi pool le dan un triunfo al Sí en el
referéndum en las ocho preguntas es
decir las propuestas que ha impulsado el
gobierno a través de este referéndum
habrán sido ratificadas por la consulta
al pueblo ecuatoriano con lo cual
empieza todo un proceso de reformas
legales y de algunas enmiendas
constitucionales que cambiarán de alguna
manera el panorama institucional aunque
no en la medida ni con los profundidad
que esperaría una situación tan crítica
como la que atraviesa el país
actualmente Bueno una de las principales
y más polémicas cuestiones es la
extradición de criminales vinculados con
organizaciones transnacionales Qué se
entiende por organización transnacional
Y a quién podría afectar principalmente
bueno esta pregunta está en el enmarcada
en lo que es el convenio de Palermo
sobre la lucha contra el crimen
organizado transnacional dentro de estas
organizaciones de crimen organizado
transnacional se identifica entre las
entre otras fundamentalmente aquellas
dedicadas al narcotráfico aquellas
dedicadas por ejemplo a trata de
personas entre otros delitos
y el lavado de activos que es otro de
los tres más relevantes la pregunta lo
que proponía es romper la prohibición
constitucional que tenemos en el Ecuador
de que un connacional un ciudadano
ecuatoriano o naturalizado como
ecuatoriano pueda ser extraditado a otro
país que lo requiera para ser juzgado
por uno de estos delitos con esta
consulta y al haberse aprobado se
abriría la posibilidad de que por
ejemplo si Estados Unidos el día de
mañana requiere a un ciudadano
ecuatoriano como
involucrado en red de narcotráfico
transnacional el gobierno ecuatoriano si
es que se lleva a cabo este proceso
judicial de extradición podría cederle
jurisdicción para que sea juzgado en
territorio estadounidense y no en
territorio ecuatoriano habla usted de
Estados Unidos ha podido haber algún
tipo de entendimiento entre el gobierno
ecuatoriano y el de Estados Unidos para
llevar a cabo esta medida sin duda
alguna Nosotros sabemos que desde hace
ya al menos dos años claramente Estados
Unidos está acompañando a Ecuador en el
desarrollo de una estrategia de de
seguridad que está enmarcada en lo que
ya conocemos como guerra como contra las
drogas que se aplicó en Colombia en su
debido momento que se aplicó en México
que se ha aplicado en algunos otros
sitios de América Latina parte de la
narrativa de la guerra contra las drogas
es precisamente la extradición de los
cabecillas de los líderes porque esto
catapulta políticamente a los gobiernos
que intentan mostrar en la extradición
de líder de un grupo narcotraficante o
narco delictivo un triunfo o un éxito de
su política de seguridad el problema de
esta narrativa es que tiene un costo
humano enorme y ya estamos viendo las
consecuencias en el caso del Ecuador
donde el año anterior rompimos el récord
a la tasa de homicidios más alta de toda
nuestra historia
se busca dar también ahora más
Independencia a la fiscalía en qué
ayudaría este hipotética Independencia a
reducir el crimen en el país
en la idea que está detrás de la
pregunta era constituir o es constituir
un consejo que dirija la fiscalía
general del estado y que la independice
de la función judicial tal como estaba
concebida en el diseño originario de la
Constitución desde la perspectiva
optimista diríamos una fortalecimiento
de la fiscalía en este sentido le daría
mayores competencias para poder
asignarse recursos y distribuirlos en
las enormes necesidades económicas que
tiene esta institución tan importante
para la investigación de los delitos
pero desde la perspectiva pesimista
podríamos nosotros tener que en este
consejo fiscal haya una mayor presencia
y control por parte del ejecutivo lo que
terminaría convirtiéndole a la fiscalía
en un instrumento político más del
gobierno de turno